it's an incredibly boring day he gets up
he has his bowl of oatmeal he heads to
the office where he stays right up until
dinner and and and then he goes home or
he there's some event more and more
because his wife Wendy likes to go to
events then he'll go out to an event of
which he will struggle to stay awake
through and then he will go to sleep and
get up again and have his bowl of
oatmeal and commence the next day
well one of his key lieutenants called
me up and and and said after reading the
book and said but but it's all about him
and I said well it it is a biography and
then he says but it's so personal so I I
think that that one of the things that
happened is Rupert was just surprised by
the nature of the book I really think
there was a point that actually I I
interviewed Rupert's mother who's 102
years old and she lives in Australia and
and I arrived there and she said oh it's
very curious that that that my son is
helping you with this book because you
know he's never read one so I I actually
think that this is part of the issue
that that that he he really was a kind
of unfamiliar with what a what a modern
biography might be like and was rather
anticipating a sort of a resuscitation I
think of his of his deals and and in the
course of his career rather than a book
that tried to understand who this man is
and actually give of give a a taste of
his true character
we we have we have not I I think the the
the Cold War between us has just gotten
colder
hence I was one of those those those
moments where I think well James James
turned to me and and said some lifts at
me and said something like oh not you
and then there was a moment in which I
mean James's as actually has kind of a
hair-trigger temper and and you could
see him measuring whether he should fly
off the handle or stay in control and he
in fact stayed in control and I was with
my son who he turned to and and was
polite and charming to turned away from
me
I think
matters his company matters his
newspapers matter to him his moral
Center is is is is is different because
he doesn't he feels he he doesn't feel
necessarily part of our world it is his
world that he's a part of I think he
sees himself as as as relatively remote
from the rest of us he is in a sense a
nation-state unto himself and so his
first interest is is is protecting his
world
he grows up the Murdochs 400 years the
Murdoch family has been among the most
important and prominent and powerful
families in Australia so I think he's
always had a sense of himself as a
person apart and as he's built his
company and he built it in for more than
40 years has has been building this
company in countries other than his own
I think that it has been a very key
aspect of of how he regards everyone
else and himself that he is is not quite
of the communities he lives in
for Rupert himself his death he is 79
years old this is inevitable and that
will be the key factor in his in the
future of his company this is a a kind
of unique company because it is really
has been it's a very large company as a
public company but nevertheless is the
expression of one man it's about his
interests his obsessions his point of
view so it necessarily changes
dramatically erratically and quickly
when he's no longer there the the one of
the the key focuses of his company one
of the key businesses remains newspapers
and and there are very very few people
in the media business and few people in
his own family who believe that there is
much currency or or economic life left
in newspapers
whereas Rupert himself believes that
they are continued to be singularly the
most important influence in his life our
lives and in the life of his company